it was by orders of magnitude the
hardest thing I've written an unquiet
mind wasn't hard to write in terms of
the actual writing of it with an unquiet
mind it was extremely hard to decide to
write it there were a lot of things that
made it difficult to go public and that
was very anxiety producing but writing
the book that I wrote now nothing was
the same was difficult it was really
hard it was hard writing and it was hard
to decide to write it but it was
necessary
I think because I had written an unquiet
mind it was that book I saw very much as
a combination of advocacy and for mental
illness but also trying to describe what
the experience of bipolar illness was
like Oh in my experience with my own
family even though my mother is a deeply
apathetic wonderful woman she had no way
of conceptualizing what mania was for
example what what I felt like when I was
manic or suicidally depressed so it was
a descriptive book and and with this
book with nothing was the same this was
really I think more along the lines of
an LG which is a very very different
sort of thing with writing memoir about
mental illness there have been a lot of
memoirs in the last 10 years 15 years
but elegies I have a history of
thousands of years there's a what it's a
wonderful aspect of grief that it is so
much a part of the human condition
that's so Universal that people have
written about it so it's a very
different kind of writing it's very
different kind of thinking
some cases I mean some people do get
depressed in the middle of their grief
and they really need to be treated for
depression but what I wanted to do was
make the distinction as many people have
is that grief is fundamentally a healthy
sort of thing it's human it's not a
disease it's nothing you want to
medicalize you don't want to treat it
away you don't want people to suffer
unnecessarily but you you certainly
don't want to to take away the
experience of that kind of
reestablishment of relationship in
depression it's the experiences
unremitting for the most part I mean
it's not like you don't get very much of
a break from depression grief is
different grief is much more title it
comes and goes it's anybody who has
grieved knows and will describe that
those that just being swept by a wave of
grief you think that you're over it you
think you're to the other side and then
all of a sudden you get blindsided by a
wave of grief and each one of those
waves of grief iein convinced serves a
good function in the mind and heart in
terms of forcing you to have to see
someone is slightly different light each
time is slightly different less painful
depression is just unremitting it is
much more disruptive of sleep it's much
you're much more likely to be impaired
intellectually with depression it just
goes on and on and people think about
suicide its grief is can be can respond
to the environment it can respond to
solace well one thing's that's very
interesting is that literature does help
I mean I think that you know when you're
depressed you can't concentrate long
enough and well enough to read for the
most part some people can but by and
large people that's one of the first
things that goes is the capacity to read
meaningful literature with grief that's
not true I mean it for a while you can't
read but then you really are amenable
sauce you get from friends from family
from colleagues from the rites of church
whatever it is music poetry and in my
case I turned more to literature
and I found it immensely helpful
well I had read Tennyson's in memoriam
when I was 17 years old and in high
school and I had a psychotic depressive
break at that time and I I read him and
I stood in awe of his capacity to
capture that cut the rhythms of life you
know the the despair and the
regeneration and the hope and I suppose
that there's there's something in
Tennyson I turned to him after my
husband died it was that you you read
this and you you're in the presence of
somebody who has been wrecked by pain
there's none of the kind of tidying up
it is it is agonizing pain and he
doesn't make any apologies for that
whatsoever and it goes over it's a poem
that was written over 9 years and over
the seasons and Christmas - Christmas -
Christmas and the tolling of the bells
and each time there's a different
tolling of the bells each time there's a
different aspect of the Christmas season
and there's something in that to me that
captures grief each year it is different
I don't think grief of grief in a
medical way at all I think that I and
many of my colleagues are very concerned
when grief becomes pathological but
there's no question that grief can
trigger depression and vulnerable people
and there's no question that depression
can make grief worse and all those
people you really want to treat but
overwhelmingly people will do well by
grief I mean this is it's the furthest
thing from a medical condition this is a
human condition it is you know from
literally the first death someone
mourned that wasn't sick that was that's
our capacity to appreciate that what we
are missing and so I think it's I think
it's a terrible thing to think of it as
in any ways pathological it can become
pathological but no I again I think that
I just came out with a respect for grief
that I never thought I would have
with incredible difficulty I think that
I think the initial days and weeks are
protected a bit by shock that society
tells you there are certain things you
have to do there's certain legal things
you have to do there's certain that's
the funeral all those things the
arrangements that keep you kind of
occupied up to a point
it's those devastating moments when you
start going through clothes and letters
and correspondence and keys and all
those private things that were someone
else's that you just you learn different
things I mean it's it is deeply private
I mean there's no question about it and
I think that you know people understand
up to a point but nobody can understand
because for each person that loses that
person the memories are any syncretic
you know you are the one that remembers
what your relationship was and that is
incredibly private and you're the one
who recognizes the things that you will
no longer have you know that you you're
gonna have to do things on your own you
know there's just that you just can't
rely on someone's support and love you
you're gonna have to do it yourself and
so I think one thing is just to
recognize up front that's going to be
really hard and secondly that other
people can be really wonderful if you've
got good friends it's great
and also again to to reach out for
solace because I do think you can get
sols sometimes through music sometimes
through religion sometimes through
reading sometimes through friends but
usually through friends and family
we're as free it's very odd and one of
the things that I wrote about in my
current book was the experience of going
public and an unquiet mind and the the
public and professional reprecussions of
that the loss of privacy and one of the
things that was very hard for me aside
for the the professional aspects of
talking about having been psychotic and
having tried to kill myself and
realizing I was going to have to go
faced my colleagues in academic medicine
was that I was really brought up like
most people to really keep your personal
life private and I was brought up in the
military and I'm an Episcopalian and
such things don't make you very likely
to put your private life out there and I
was brought up in the family where you
kept you know a really warm family I
love my family deeply but you know you
sort of got a grip and you didn't talk
and my husband oddly enough who was very
reserved man was the one who really
pushed me about him in quiet mind
because he said you know I said on the
one hand I had all these reservations of
privacy and professional things and on
the other hand I thought it was the
right thing to do we as an advocate that
people needed to talk about these things
and and he studied schizophrenia and he
treated people who had schizophrenia and
he said you know there's an obligation
to do it he and I will back you and of
course it's personal of course is
private and of course it's gonna be
excruciating for you and you know for
the first I don't know 30 or 40 times I
got I've been talked about my manias and
depressions all I could think of was my
grandmother you know with her white
clothes and her hat and you know I would
just be mortified I was thinking what am
i doing talking about this how could I
possibly talk about having tried to kill
myself how could I do this and yet you
know
at the other day you know this is you
don't because you you hope that it will
help it be one part one small piece in
making people more comfortable about it
you know people can talk about having
breast cancer why can't people who have
mental
talk about mental illness until we're
able to do that we're not going to be
treated with the same kind of respect
for our diseases as other people and and
my husband saw that absolutely clearly
and so you know I shall a fair amount of
the first part of the book is about how
he dealt with my own illness but also
how he encouraged me and I and I think
that's where the role of other people
nobody has a disease alone you have a
disease with other people around you and
I was very fortunate and having this
particular person in my life